coup d'envoi de la troisième saison
culturelle samedi 12 septembre à la
commanderie pour l'occasion une soirée
d'animation est organisée ce lieu est
très conviviale donc l'objectif c'est
que les petits et les grands se
retrouvent dans une ambiance conviviale
dans une ambiance festive et joyeuse
pour démarrer cette saison culturelle
qui se veut ambitieuse avec de nombreux
événements qui vont là jalonné tout au
long de la saison
spectacle de danse chariot pour réaliser
des expériences scientifiques
combi volkswagen dans lequel on pourra
écouter de la poésie les animations sont
variés l'objectif c'est de faire
participer parce que la volonté de 2,50
en yvelines c'est une culture qui soit
tournée vers les habitants est à la fois
la culture va au devant des habitants et
les habitants doivent venir aussi au
devant en plus des animations des food
truck seront présents pour permettre aux
habitants de se restaurer dans la
convivialité
l'événement sera donc un avant goût des
temps forts de la saison sur le prochain
trimestre il y aura donc les journées du
patrimoine dont une partie se passera
ici il y aura un week-end science et
puis il y aura le fameux noël décalé que
tout le monde attende non depuis l'année
dernière la saison culturelle tournera
autour de plusieurs thèmes comme les
arts visuels la science ou encore la
poésie la soirée de lancement elle
débutera à 17h et sera gratuite